le liban vit sa pire crise économique
depuis la fin de la guerre civile il ya
vingt ans une situation dramatique qui
dure depuis neuf mois et qui est
amplifié par les mesures de confinement
liêu coronavirus la livre libanaise a
perdu à plus de la moitié de sa valeur
face au dollar
les projections d'inflation sont
propulsés à plus de 50% sur l'année 2020
et d'après les estimations officielles
près d'un habitant sur deux vit
actuellement sous le seuil de pauvreté
ce jeudi beyrouth a tenté de rassurer la
population
le chef du gouvernement libanais s'est
engagé à freiner la dégringolade de la
monnaie nationale et à subventionner les
produits de base et j'annonce ici que
les procédures ont déjà commencé le
gouverneur de la banque centrale m'a
promis que la banque du liban
interviendrait sur le marché dès
maintenant pour protéger la livre
libanaise et freiner la hausse du taux
de change
j'annonce également que l'importation de
produits alimentaires de base sera
subventionné selon un calendrier fixe
qu'il y aura un suivi quotidien afin de
réduire les prix des denrées
alimentaires et que les libanais à
sisteron bientôt à une baisse des prix
de ses produits
un discours tenus à l'occasion du
centième jour de l'entrée en fonction du
gouvernement dans un pays en pleine
débâcle financière
jadis le grenier à blé de l'est de la
méditerranée le liban fait face à un
risque d'une crise alimentaire majeure
d'après les autorités
de nombreux libanais ont par exemple
cessé d'acheter de la viande des fruits
et des légumes
il pourrait même bientôt avoir du mal à
se payer du pain et une population à
bout et qui est confronté depuis
plusieurs jours à des coupures de
courant dans certaines régions des
habitants se retrouvent sans électricité
pendant près de 12 heures défilé un
ras-le-bol que certains libanais ont
exprimé ce jeudi en tentant de pénétrer
dans les locaux du ministère de
l'énergie dans la capitale les
manifestants ont notamment scandé des
slogans contre la corruption et le
gaspillage de l'argent public
l'état corrompu nous a coupé
l'électricité
il y à de l'électricité au palais
présidentiel dans le bâtiment du
gouvernement
il vole de milliards de dollars par an
apporter un milliard de dollars à
dépenser en électricité et garder
l'autre milliards pour vous mais soulagé
nous nous allons nous débarrasser de
vous face à la crise économique les
manifestations anti-gouvernement donc
repris depuis plus de trois semaines
malgré le confinement liban un pays qui
croule sous une dette de 92 milliards de
dollars soit 170 % du pib
en octobre dernier la crise économique
avait déjà été l'un des déclencheurs
d'un soulèvement inédit contre la classe
politique accusée de corruption et
d'incompétence